all right alexis
yes alexis uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i was born in
connecticut and then moved to
new york and was raised there um since i
was seven
and tell me about your family so my
birth mother
and birth father
um it was a little chaotic they
were
on and off drugs while my mother was
pregnant with me
um
and then when i was born i think they
tried to give it a little bit of a
chance like they really wanted to
see if they could get their lives
together
and
raise me
but um i ended up being taken away it
was kind of a weird situation
i think cps was doing just a routine
check in the apartment
and they had looked over everything and
everything was good and they just wanted
to check out my nursery and i think my
parents were kind of like
alexis is sleeping
um i was like a very young baby and
they're like well we still have to check
things out in there they ended up
checking out my nursery and finding that
they had hidden all their
drugs etc
underneath my crib mat while i was
taking a nap on it so
at that point
i was removed and put in foster care
for about three years
and then i was adopted by my great aunt
so it was like a
family adoption so i am with my family
just distant family um
yeah
so how did that affect your your
childhood being raised by someone other
than your biological parents so it has
been
a little easier because i am within my
family it's not a completely different
like another country adoption or a close
adoption or anything like that
but still hard because you're not you
know being raised by your biological
parents so there's an aspect of
abandonment there
and even if you know them
sometimes i think it's harder to know
them because you know that
maybe they're choosing not to raise you
instead of knowing nothing and just
having it be kind of
a mystery
as a young girl was was that your
perception
yes i i definitely think i was wondering
a lot why my mom had
chosen drugs over me when i was younger
that's how i thought
now that i'm older i know it's much more
complicated than that
but
i was adopted with my older sibling
about three years older than me and he
actually
um ended up having some mental illness
like bipolar some anger issues things
like that
as we grew up just through like
kindergarten elementary school as
behavioral issues were really showing
like
tantrums that weren't normal like
biting hitting kicking teachers and
things like that so i would like i have
memories of when i was younger just
hearing about those things hearing that
my brother had been kicked out of a
school and we would move schools all the
time
so it was a little bit stressful for me
but
when i was seven my brother was 10
my mother my birth mother ended up
passing away um
[Music]
my adopted parents told me approached it
like she passed away in her sleep
which
they i guess they never really clarified
but i knew that it meant
kinda she had overdosed but how do you
really tell that to a seven-year-old so
but i'm happy my parents were honest
with me they were always honest about
everything
where i came from why i was adopted
you know that my mother had passed away
it was just kind of hard because
i didn't have any memory of my birth
mother but
the one memory i do have is of going to
her funeral which is not very great when
it's an open casket funeral
so in my head that's my image of my
birth mother
when people ask me if i if oh do i
remember her i'm just kind of like avoid
the question because it's like
i don't but you know i saw her in her
casket that's kind of the only time i
have pictured her
besides in photos which there are a lot
of pictures of us when i was little
um
what was your drug
i think it was a lot of cocaine i ended
up being a heroin overdose at the end
but um it was a lot of that while she
was pregnant with me a lot of the family
members knew that she was pregnant with
me and at that time she had been not
accepting treatment and just didn't
really want to
help herself so i think everyone was
kind of worried
what would come of me when i was born
but i ended up being okay which i'm
grateful for um
yeah so
after that things kind of got
bad i would say my childhood overall
was
i think the word i would say is just a
little chaotic
i think my birth parents really had good
intentions
but i think even they didn't really know
what they were dealing with with my
brother and then it was hard to also
have me there kind of
needing them but they had spent their
energy on him
some examples are when he was going
through
like his early teen years like 12 13 14
they're really trying to figure out the
medication that he should be on
to even everything out make him act a
little better
and i think just going through the
medication just
switching it up all the time it really
upset him because when you're on the
wrong medication you can kind of feel
like a zombie
you just feel not good and i think
there's a
time where he was just sick and tired of
feeling like i think maybe
a test monkey for the medication
so when he was 13 or 14 he decided he
just wasn't going to take any of his
medication anymore which you can't make
someone you know take their medication
and i think at that point he had turned
to
some drugs
it wasn't
that crazy i think he just started
smoking some weed i think at that point
um
i had caught in like
smells of it our bedrooms were like
right next to each other
and so
i think i was i'd get really internally
upset because i always felt like me and
him knew better like me and him just
knew that because of what our mom had
gone through that
we just wouldn't do things that way we
would just learn from her
mistakes
so i think that was the age i really
started
getting
a little angry at him
on the inside just because i didn't
understand why he was doing those things
again this is like
very different from when i think now
but when i was younger i just really had
a lot of anger towards him
for going down a certain path but
he ended up really getting into the
drugs
he had a little hard time in school he
had a couple learning disabilities like
it was hard for him to read it was hard
for him to
write and just comprehend learning in a
normal environment so i think that made
him angry and upset
so
um he would act out a lot and at that
point we were kind of in the same
school so when we were
for one year we were in high school
together he was a senior and i was a
freshman or a sophomore and it was just
kind of embarrassing because
all of my friends knew him everyone in
the school knew that we were related and
he was kind of just like
screaming yelling cursing he tried to
attack the principal and then everyone
kind of comes to me like
what is your brother doing what what is
going on in your household and i think
it was just kind of something i tried to
avoid and separate myself from um
i think that i really
tried to just take the approach of not
being involved within my own home
and that came with
my relationship with my parents
was very
hard because i just didn't agree with
how they were handling things with my
brother i think that i um
i think that i blamed them sometimes for
how he acted because i felt like they
just let him
run the household
which was hard because i felt like his
actions were affecting me he was very
violent
he would attack them he wouldn't attack
me he would attack them he would also
attack the house itself like punching
holes in walls and throwing things and
things like that
and when i was younger it was very scary
for me to watch that and just listen to
that happening outside my bedroom door
and my parents were very
i think lenient before they would call
the police even if they should have been
like um
calling them much much sooner i think
they called them at the last minute
just because he was so uncontrollable i
mean he was like six three two hundred
pounds like
angry and mentally ill a lot of times
like drug induced
rage so it's not something you can
subdue um
so there's a lot of cops at my house
like when it was bad it would be once a
week when it wasn't as bad it would be
like twice a month
and yeah that's how we grew up together
and you
eventually finish school
yeah so i graduated high school well
actually i'll bring it back a little bit
because
my um
senior year of high school was when
life kind of changed a lot
i joined my track team i made a lot of
new friends and i really felt like i was
feeling better from my home situation
because i was out of my home
which was really nice but at the same
time things were really not good at my
house i think my brother had gotten
pulled over for
i think he had some drugs on him i
forgot the exact amount but he ended up
catching a felony
and for that felony he went to
jail for six months it was really
weird because
i heard that and i just realized like he
just wouldn't be around for six months
like the house would be silent there'd
be no fighting there'd be no screaming
no nothing and it was just
kind of
weird
um
from hearing all the noises and the
yelling and everything my entire life
until that moment
it i don't know i just felt like i was
comfortable in the chaos
but
there came a point where
we were writing to each other i'd
written him a letter because i felt
like i just wanted to tell him that
you know
i was wishing well for him
and that i was hoping like you know that
he would come back and
be better or maybe just think of me more
in the house and what i would have to go
through with everything that he was
doing so i just wrote him a letter and
he ended up writing me one back
and he was just saying um
that he was sorry
and he said that he wanted to change and
he said that he really
thought that this time he would which is
you know something that addicts say but
i think i liked it because he had
written me a letter that i still have
but he came back from
jail and things were good for a little
while but then they got bad again i
think he just kept doing the drugs and
he
got back into hanging out with the same
people
and he got comfortable at home again and
he stopped worrying about
himself being on probation and he just
thought like
he was good to go he didn't have to
worry about getting in trouble
and he just wanted to live his life how
he wanted to live it
and i think that um
he got too comfortable
um also we also had one of his friends
staying at our home at my parents home
with me and him
because he needed some place to
stay for a little bit my parents were
always like
welcoming everyone with open arms
and so they would stay downstairs in the
lower portion of my house kind of a
little bit separate from everyone else
and
at that point there's like just not good
stuff going on i think they were kind of
like
selling drugs i think they would have
kind of like people over that just
weren't great people and i think that
made my situation my parents worse
because
i would talk to them and just ask them
like why are you allowing this why are
you
letting these people in our home
when i live here you know i'm in high
school i want to have my friends over i
want to feel safe and i just want to
feel like this is a place where
i can relax and not be
scared
but
i mean it our conversation didn't really
go very far my parents were kind of
stuck in their ways with him they wanted
to keep him as close as they could just
so they can
keep him safe i think that's what they
thought they were doing if they if they
had him in the house
even doing whatever he wanted they at
least knew what he was doing knew where
he was and that he would come home to
them
but eventually
it ended up
where i was at
a track meet um
where i used to go for track meets i
would have no reception on my phone so
when i would get back on the bus coming
back to my high school all my messages
would pop up then
and so a message just popped up on my
phone from my mother and she just said
um
ask jason what he wants for dinner and
then i messaged her i was like oh i'm
not home yet i have a meet and so
after i got home from my track meet um a
couple of friends and i went out to eat
we got some dinner
and then weirdly my friend
my other friend texted me and was like
do you want to come over and just check
out my art project it was getting pretty
late and it was a school night so it was
like
something i usually wouldn't do but i
just felt like i wanted to stop by his
house that night so i did
and i was sitting with him at his
kitchen table he's explaining to me his
art project and then there was a ring on
the door
and my
um friend's mom was like hey alexis like
your dad's here and i was like why would
my dad be here at my friend's house it's
kind of like very
random um
so i went down to see him he was
standing on the porch and
he just looked at me and he was like
he told me jason's dead
and
i think
it's really hard for me to like recount
this story i feel like i don't remember
a lot of it after that moment it kind of
is all blurred together
i remember going home
to my house with him i think he had me
follow him home because he was worried
about me driving but he wanted to tell
me as soon as he could that's why he
came to get me
we went home
and
i walked in my house and my mother
was just there and
there was just really not much talking
going on um
i think that night i ended up going in
my room and just like
i don't know just i think i looked at a
couple pictures of it it just didn't
feel real it was just hours after i had
found out it felt like
it wasn't real but
um
i guess my mom had texted me like ask
jason what he wants for dinner so i
would like go downstairs and see
like hey what do you want for dinner i
think she was just going to pick
something up
but
i ended up being out so she
ended up coming home
and
she was
i think she got like undressed for work
she was starting to cook some food she
knew that him and his friend were
downstairs like doing whatever usually
play video games or just like
chill smoke weed something like that so
she went downstairs
to see what he wanted for dinner
and i think she just opened his door
and he was just in his bed sleeping
she thought and then she tried to wake
him up and he was gone
him and his friend had both snorted some
heroin beforehand i think they ended up
just like
hanging out a little and then both
taking naps like separately in their
separate areas but um
my brother
i don't know i think
his friend was fine his friend woke up
to my mom yelling and screaming and
like
really
didn't i don't think she knew what to do
besides calling it 9-1-1 which she did
but my my brother's friend woke up and
he was fine they had done the same exact
thing
um
[Music]
but i think by the time my mom had gone
down just to see what he wanted to eat
it wasn't it was too late even at that
point and that was even before the
paramedics could get there
so um
yeah and then
there was a big service with all of our
families from
each of our side because me and my
brother shared a mom but had different
dads
the service felt really really weird
because
it was all the same people from my mom's
funeral
and they were back here again for my
brother
and i think everyone was just so
just in disbelief that this had happened
because it was
i guess it wasn't that
it was a shock with my mom but she had
had such a long past of drugs and just
bad decisions i think
my mom was only 27 when she passed away
my brother passed away when he was 20.
so
i think the just
amount of like
shock was just in the room i mean i felt
really weird because it was the first
time
in a long time that attention was on me
at all in general usually as i said like
my parents were very focused on him and
his needs because
he had a lot of them a lot more than i
did i kind of floated through my
schooling
i had friends i had hobbies and i just
tried to stay away but
everyone was just
looking at me and i think they just
didn't know what to
say
i didn't know what to say either because
it was just like
it's hard to lose someone that you
don't have a good relationship with
um me and him weren't very close i mean
we were so different and i felt like he
caused me a lot of
pain growing up because of just all i
had to witness in the house and just the
attention from my parents being focused
on him
and um
so when it's a situation where it's like
maybe you have some animosity or maybe
you're just not
close
and someone someone that you have that
type of relationship with dies
it's
really hard to
heal from that because there's no i mean
there's never closure and death but
especially when you and your head had i
mean when i was younger i really hated
my brother
um
and i guess i would always think about
how i never got to tell him
i didn't hate him
um i think that
he knew and i think by especially the
letter he had written me when he was in
jail um
he knew that he had caused me a lot of
hurt and he was very apologetic about it
and i think that
i just wish i had been able to give him
something like that just like
tell him or show him that i did care
about him but it was just really hard
being
in an environment that was just so
crazy and violent and
so
that was hard and then just adding that
up with my mom who
you know went the same way it just was
really tragic because like i said i was
really mad
at my brother for doing drugs and doing
those things but
i learned
a lot since my brother has passed away i
think that i mean
it makes you just become a new person
because you just realize like
i had well i had some family members who
had some things to say about you know
how he had acted when he was here
and just about
you know
how maybe he wasn't a great guy anyway
and things like that
but
i think that when i heard them saying
those things it really made me change
how i felt because i was like
he was going through probably torture
mentally
he was not doing the things that he was
doing
because he wanted to
he was struggling every day
every time he would get super violent
and attack my parents or at the house or
anything in general like that afterwards
by the time the cops would come
he would be crying
upset with himself
so
he wasn't a bad person
and
i think that honestly he was a good
person because i saw him be a friend
i saw him be a good
older cousin i saw him playing with kids
it just is
a part of him that we saw the least
which is unfortunate but i think that
part of him
is who he was
um
and just his mental illness was it
wasn't him it just was something he was
struggling with and i think that
it proves that after all his episodes
like that he would be crying
it shows that he really was bothered by
how
he acted it shows that like
he
and times he felt embarrassed um if i
would have a friend over and he would
realize that after he was screaming and
yelling
um
i think that
from both of these experiences now i've
had a lot of time to think i mean my
brother passed away in 2017.
um how old are you now
22. 19. yeah i was 17. um which oh
brings me back to that was
mid my uh senior year of high school
so that really changed things for me um
i couldn't really join in with the
excited for college
ready to start my life crowd
that you know all my friends were in i
kind of my life kind of was on pause for
a little bit because
i just couldn't
do school work like i used to i just
couldn't
focus
i mean grief is
very strange
i think i distracted myself for a good
two years
and when covet happened during
florentine when all i had to do was sit
in my house i think i really faced it
[Music]
i think that's when it really hit me
that he was gone
i think that
one of the biggest things i've taken
away for myself
is probably that
i mean i struggle
mentally i think besides the those
events of my mother and my brother
passing away and the things that we
that i had watched in my house
besides those things
i struggled with my mental health
but
i realized that
getting to
i mean
it sounds weird but i feel privileged to
have a life
even if it's hard even if i'm sad or i'm
mad or it sucks or something bad happens
i feel like
i mean i've just seen waste of life in
front of me i mean my mom was 27 and my
brother was 20. i feel like they got to
really
do
not saying nothing but they really
didn't get a chance um
so
i've never felt like i wanted didn't
want to be here
because
i just think
i'm lucky to be here even if it's hard
to be here even if it's lonely to be
here without them um
which is hard too because it's just like
i don't know i think when my brother
passed away i really felt like
questioning why me like
you know how could this happen to me you
know
walking around with just feeling sad and
lost and
so many questions about my mom and then
my brother i think
i knew he was doing drugs
but in my head i had convinced myself
that he would just always be here
it sounds weird but i thought he would
just always be here annoying me i
thought he would just always be around
and that i would just never get rid of
him and he just made me so mad all the
time and i was just like it wasn't even
a thought in my mind
that he wouldn't be here
and he's not and you know
i think it has taught me a lot i think i
have learned a lot of lessons that
people maybe learn a little later in
life
what kind of things have you learned
i think
i mean the one thing is just to be
grateful for having a life
another thing is just to be people just
need to be empathetic
i thought i saw a lot of people just not
being empathetic towards my brother his
whole life
and
it was hard because you know people will
see someone
who's mentally ill and i think they just
expect them to
you know just get up just get over it
just take your meds just get your life
together and that's it or they see
someone doing drugs and
they just decide that it's a choice
they're just choosing to do drugs and
that's that's the end of the
conversation
and i mean
just the fact that my mom
couldn't raise me due to the fact that
she was doing so many drugs i think that
really shows that
i mean it is a choice
but it is
a lot deeper than that
and i've had to forgive that's another
thing i've learned
forgive
my mom forgive my brother for a lot of
things while he was here and i mean now
that he's gone i've forgiven him for a
lot more things which
i wish had happened sooner but um
yeah i think that the most important
thing is just really
to be
it sounds cheesy but to be nice
to everyone
if you can because you just never know
i think
people i grew up with never knew what
was going on in my house and
i think they just could have been a
little kinder
because when they found out i think they
really
they might have felt a little bad
that i walk around like i had a thicker
skin than i i did i like to make a lot
of
humor out of things um
but
i do feel everything that i've been
through and it is hard for me so
i've learned also just to be honest
about my feelings and not
brush over them um
yeah empathy
it's very important
yeah all right alexis thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you i wish
you the best of luck from here on out
thank you
you